hello my name is Connor I'm 20 years old
I'm an ex a theist and I currently
identify as Christian hi my name is
Brian Morgan I'm 47 years old I'm an ex
Christian and I now identify as
somewhere between agnostic atheist
spiritual somewhere in there
where did you grow up I was born and
raised in Shrewsbury Massachusetts
it's very suburban so when I say
Massachusetts everyone thinks Boston but
it's an hour west of Boston it's a
pretty large suburban town mostly white
people so I ran for the hills literally
and metaphorically I grew up in
Washington states moved around a lot all
over the west coast I think my oming is
as far east as I went as a kid but yeah
mostly West Coast Washington kind of a
home base
what was your primary religion growing
up my mom identifies as Catholic but she
never pushed the religion on to me for
the longest time I was actually when I
was little I didn't think about it but
then once they started becoming a
teenager and kind of developing my own
ideas and kind of identifying as Who I
am as a gay man I kind of thought
religion was terrifying especially of
the things that I heard I thought I
wanted to avoid that at all cost and I
didn't want identify as that so that's
why I was strictly atheist and I was
like a proud a theist Christianity
mostly evangelical Christianity a little
bit of Baptist a little bit uh
nondenominational I had leadership roles
growing up in in the church
just in high school even I was head of
some youth group functions and things
like that I had a father figure as a
youth pastor and that led me into
becoming a youth pastor myself right out
of college for two years and it was not
a good fit I was it was something I
idealized in this person and I thought I
could be like him and it just I wasn't
cut out for it it what led you to change
your beliefs the defining moment is when
I moved to San Diego actually last year
I was in an uber driver and I was
talking to the uber about wigeon all
this stuff and we got talking I loved
what she was saying and it was very open
and it was very missing mindset an idea
that I had but instead of being atheist
she was Christian and she actually
brought me to church so I had to charge
in the uber driver and after that I
literally I got the Bible and I started
reading the Bible I started going to
church with her and all this stuff and
it was it sounds like it was a quick
easy change I mean before that I was
kind of is in my mind but she really
guided me and also she showed me this
path that wasn't she was gonna normalize
and like an easygoing and accepting
and so I was like okay I can be this and
I like this and I it's a comforting idea
now let's funny every word ever forget
it I'm like this is a lesson here like I
honestly believe like boys are concepts
so this is this is tricky it happens
instantaneously and over time I think
the biggest like precipitating factor
was about three years ago a big job
change was gonna happen I had some
prophecies that told me that that was
going to happen and then that all fell
through and so it got me questioning
like you know why did that happen why
did these prophecies happen why did God
tell me this was gonna happen and then
it didn't and then I turned that pain
outward and looked into the world the
question of suffering just was never
thoroughly answered for me why doesn't
he take care of cancer why doesn't he
take care of kids getting shot in
schools and it was painful to see that
God didn't care what does your family
think of your change of beliefs it's
funny I kinda like came out that's like
a question to my family which is a
little funny
my mom she once again she was never
pushing religion on to me but when I
told her I think she was happy just
because I think just sponging religion
for her means like finding a path and
finding guidance and things and
especially with the things I was going
through I thought she thought it was
good for me and it was my sisters were
skeptical cuz my sisters are atheist so
they were like tell like what's going on
here but they're all very accepting and
um my grandma loves it this was kind of
tough cuz we're in process right now I
have four kids teens and adults and they
are mostly dealing okay with it although
there's some sticking points I was
nervous especially telling the kids when
I made that decision though it was it
was a positive decision I felt free and
I was excited to share that freedom with
others but at the same time it was it
was complicated how has your life
changed since you switched your beliefs
it's funny now I'm always been a
grateful and appreciative boy and
everything but now more than ever I you
know I I think God for everything you
know even like a bed and a food or like
this like whole opportunity is like
amazing and you know I see everything
also has this higher power of the divine
timing of it and this is supposed to be
happening and you know even though crazy
things happen like things suck when they
happen but you know God has lessons to
be taught and to be learned and I look
at it that way so now I will get
everything as a learning opportunity and
that
I truly believe that this is all
supposed to be happening in that even
right now there's something to be
learned or even on the walk here there
was something to be learned so it's kind
of like I'm more open and more like
reflective I guess on things and I'm
looking at things from a larger
perspective not just me in my own life
like very small it's more of like
there's a bigger thing going on here I'm
in the middle of this so the the change
I don't I don't know yet how it's
changed it it still feels very fresh
it's mostly like positive energy I'm
feeling right now just this this freedom
to explore like Who I am I'm asking
myself for the first time like what do I
want whereas for the for the longest
time it was what do other people wants
and how do I serve other people and the
first shall be last etcetera things that
I used to believe that it's kept me
non-autonomous and I'm becoming more
autonomous and more myself what role if
any into spirituality play in your life
spirituality I think it's all connected
I think spirituality is the same as God
is the same as Buddha it's the same was
Allah I think it's all just like one big
thing I think it's just the
identification of it is changing between
people but you know I think also now
more than ever spirituality is becoming
this thing and I think religion is kind
of taking a good downfall because I
think religion can be intimidating a
very spiritual person but I just
identify it as God and Jesus Christ and
Mother Mary
I've used this word several times
process I'm in process now and
spirituality to me means things like
listening when friends tell me what my
astrological sign means I don't know if
I believe that yet but I'm at least like
contemplating that I think that there's
a connection for sure in the universe in
between people there's so much order and
beauty and I think that things in this
universe gravitate toward that and so
there's some kind of force I think that
is behind that I'm not sure what that is
I don't know if it's intelligent or if
it's just science or what but life is
beautiful and I'm glad to be a part of
it what is the biggest misconception
about your beliefs I think someone is
good misconceptions are actually truths
which is the scary part which is why I
was atheist at first you know there's
she missed for everything and anything
and especially with religions but I
think oh people fail to look at and
realizes that that's not everyone's
relationship with God misconceptions are
based off of the people that are just
talking louder than everyone else
there's a lot of like racist Christians
a lot of like homophobic Christians and
like transphobic Christians and it's
like you're not listening to what we're
saying and it's like you're interpreting
this Bible to be what you want I don't
believe that God would want you to hate
someone I think that this is a
completely opposite idea of religion I
think a lot of people think that
something bad must have happened that
I'm jaded that's somebody burned me and
it's none of those things it's just that
I started listening to my own thoughts
and giving them credit what do you think
about people who believe differently
than you I love it now that I did see
change I'm always open to learning other
things and I love admitting that I'm
wrong I love changing because it's like
that's the point of life I think there's
like growth here or I think all this
stuff and I think that that's how you
become the best person you can be is
changing and learning and growing from
everyone I think I'm more open to people
who believe differently than me know
since I'm kind of in this rebound phase
right now I'm a little not jaded toward
my past beliefs in Christianity but I'm
finding myself not gravitating toward
people who believe those things that'll
probably change over time so I'd say my
tolerance level is a little less for my
past beliefs than it is toward beliefs I
don't understand yet what do you think
is after death that's I think about that
a lot often especially because my sister
passed away it's I do it sounds like
some people that sounds crazy do but I
do feel her all the time she sends me
little signs and it's like call me crazy
but it's like through music or through
like anything it's undeniable I truly
believe that there is afterlife what it
is I'm not sure if because I think that
reincarnation is possible because I
think energy is neither created nor
destroyed so it's all circling somewhere
heaven in Hell seems insane to me maybe
a heaven I don't think anyone would ever
go to hell it seems kind of barbaric I
don't know is the best answer to this
but these are my guesses right now is
that we're all part of something bigger
and that our thought
our physicality our essence at least has
a mark on the universe I don't think
there's an afterlife I don't think
there's a heaven where we all get to
walk on the streets of gold or things
like that but I think what we do is
importance and that it will always be
important I used to believe that this
life was only a shadow of the future
that this was the thing we had to endure
to get to the better thing in the future
and um this is beautiful right now
and it's worth living what would you say
to someone who is questioning I would
say just to be open and to learn and to
not it's good taking other people's
perspectives and other people's opinions
but kind of have sort of tunnel vision
on your goals and on what you want to
come out of this because you know I was
influenced by someone else but you know
I took what I wanted and then it wasn't
completely her decisions there's a lot
of things in organized religion of
Christianity that I don't agree with so
it's try to just focus on your own
personal ocean ship with the God or of
the spirit of what whatever you choose
because if you're influenced by others I
think that's when it gets lost in the
sauce and you become this kind of
extremist or you become this like crazy
person and I think that's what you don't
want to become to someone who's
questioning I would say keep questioning
trust your instincts your smarts you're
capable you are good exactly as you are
and your thoughts are good your
questions are good don't be afraid of
them
[Music]
you
[Music]